When selling online
content, it's
important to deliver the correct
content to the right user
and to help you do
this, Google has
designed its best
process and guidelines
for secure transactions.
Hi, I'm Neto Marin, and I'm
going to show you some tips
and best practice to make
our transactions safer.
If you're looking for an
introduction to in-app billing
or how to use in-app
billing API in your app,
don't miss our two
previous episodes.
Some attackers or pirates can
try to hack the user's device
or pretend to be
a trusted source
and then provide wrong
responses to requests
and get your content and
items but there are three best
practices you can
follow to keep attackers
from stealing your content
and other users' items.
First, use the
developer payload, two,
signature verification,
and three,
server-side verification.
Let's take a closer
look at each.
The developer payload
is an arbitrary string
you can set to handle making
the purchase request call
and when the purchase
is completed,
or whenever you make a
call to get users purchase,
Google Play will return the
data of the same string.
So you should use some strings
to identify users' ownership
like Google Play ID or email.
Secondly, when you are using
the in-app billing API,
all responses from
Google Play are signed.
Remember, you can find your
public key in the developer
console and you should
check every request
to make sure they get
purchases and subscriptions
against that key.
With a few lines
of code, you can
check if the response was
signed using your verification
private key that
only Google has.
You can find a complete on
how to do this in the CQ Java
class of the Trivial
Drive simple app.
Another precaution you can take
if difficult attackers should
break the verification
process in the phone
is do the signature
verification on the server-side.
To do this, after getting the
response from Google Play,
you can send it to be
verified on the server-side.
These three best practices
will make your app safer
and avoid the major kinds of
attacks your app could suffer.
If you use at least a
client-side signature
verification, it's enough to
avoid the man-in-the-middle
attack but if you add the unique
developer payload [INAUDIBLE],
you can also be sure
about item ownership.
And if you also implement
the server-side verification,
your app will be safer even if
the framework is compromised.
In addition to these
security best practices,
you can take some
actions with your code
and content to
increase even more
of this security in your app.
For example, build the system to
distribute the content offered
by your app instead of packing
everything into your APK.
This protects against people
that try to open your APK
and steal resources and content.
The most basic precaution you
should take with your code
is obfuscate your in-app
billing implementation
so that it's difficult
for attackers
to reverse engineer
your security protocols
and modifications components.
In addition to running
an obfuscation program,
we recommend that you use
the following techniques
to obfuscate your
in-app billing code.
Inline methods
into other methods,
construct strings on the
fly instead of defining them
as constants, and use Java
reflection to call methods.
The in-app building
sample application
is publicly distributed and
can be downloaded by anyone,
so it's quite easy
for an attacker
to reverse engineer
your application
if you're using the
sample code exactly
as it is published
so don't do it.
If you use any part of
the simple application,
you must modify it
before you publish
or at least as part of a
[INAUDIBLE] application.
And you must protect your
Google Play public key.
To keep your public key
safe from malicious users
and hackers, do not embed it
any code as a literal string.
Instead, construct the
string at runtime from pieces
or use a bit of manipulation.
For example, XOR with another
string to hide the actual key
or download it
from your backhand.
In this case, make sure to
have a secure connection
and cryptographic before
storing in a Drive device.
For more tips about security
on Android in-app billing,
check the Security
and Design guidelines
on developer.android.com and
if you have any questions,
check our documentation
and training guides
anytime you need
and in our sample,
you can find the
convenience class to help
you validate signature
to make your app safer.
And don't forget--
security is very important.
Thanks for watching.
Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]